[Applause]
[Music]
you and kira did the footloose trend is
she okay i saw her wrist got hurt yeah
she's fine she was like she was a little
bruised up for a while i couldn't
believe she did it
we love the goat songs
and your incredible family showing off
your other talents
have you heard from taylor swift or
chris stapleton or you just threw one
out to harry styles
let me just check my phone see if harry
texted me
no i haven't heard from them yet i heard
from peter frampton
he said how much he enjoyed it so that
that was pretty cool as long as the
goats like it that's all i really care
about aside from killing it on social
media and having fun with wife kira
sedgwick kevin's been busy working with
carrie preston on a new peacock horror
film they slashed them out august 5th
where's my killer
we need to get out of here the duo play
a husband and wife team who run an
lgbtqia plus conversion camp with a
deadly outcome it's kind of like get out
meets friday the 13th and then with a
new spin you get to have the fun of the
thrills and the chills but you also get
to understand a little bit more about
the real life horrors that those
characters and the people that they
represent in the world have to go
through i feel seen
and i had never
felt seen in a script as much having
read that i was excited to play somebody
who is closer to my gender identity who
uses my pronouns what would the kevin of
more than 40 years ago who was starring
in friday the 13th think of you playing
this very unsettling role i don't know
that the kevin of four years ago was
really thinking that far ahead
how much of a dream come true is it to
work in a movie with kevin bacon
dream come true the first thing i ever
said to kevin bacon was
you know i played you sophomore year
right i was in footloo
i have a high school thing with
footloose too oh my god seriously he's
just an icon i mean he really is so down
to earth and just conversational and you
know it's like he knows who he is but he
doesn't
carry
that just enjoy the sunshine and work on
your tan
[Music]
you